[Music]
let's go out to the youth Salt Lake City
Utah and talk to Chad what up
Chad hello Dr deloney my question uh
today is
how how I may Empower my
[Applause]
wife well tell me some more Empower her
for
what well she's she's been diagnosed
with depression anxiety and AD add and
takes medication for all of those and
has done for quite some
time
and I I question her intention with it
she doesn't seen any conversation we've
had or even the the doctor that
prescribes the medication to her
encourages her to go get help uh outside
of just taking the medication but she's
pretty reluctant to
seek uh counseling
and I question I'm
questioning if I'm doing a disservice
for her when I go to pick up her
medication and I'm not encouraging
her uh to go get more than just taking
medication kind of
help and I'm really just looking for
ways that I
can help her I I've doesn't seem to be a
whole lot out there yeah I don't it's
tough how long have you been married
Chad well
been married for seven years but we've
been together for 10 hey I may be crazy
but I hear in your voice that you are
out of your mind in love with
her I am yeah and you're scared to death
am I crazy's AB no you're not I
absolutely adore it she's beautiful it's
it's difficult to tell her that because
she's she's hesitant to hear it she's
like stop I don't you know I know she's
she struggles with body image as well
that kind of get gets in the way of
things yeah and so so so here's a let's
just play that one out right one of the
challenges with loving somebody let's P
let's pull these apart real fast
somebody who struggles with body image
issues is
yeah we think that oh you just need to
hear that you're
beautiful right and actually that can
make the gap between us wider because
they're like oh you don't see it you're
crazy yeah or you're lying to me too
right
or somebody who's struggling with
depression it's easy to be like oh let's
go do something fun look how beautiful
it is and that actually in a weird
perverse
way separates us even further right yeah
I know exactly what you're saying yeah I
hate that for you man because it sounds
like she married a guy who loves her
like in a wild way and has just been
trying hard and so dude on behalf of men
everywhere who love their wives and are
just trying to do the next best right
thing I'm grateful for you man
pretty awesome appreciate ackowledgement
thank you well
I this is one of those things that you
can't just go to your buddies and talk
about it and so you end up doing a lot
of this alone and I talk to millions of
men across the not Millions but
countless men across the country and
they're dealing with the same thing I'm
trying to love my wife behind closed
doors right and I I know what to saying
about her is does no good either like
it's it's difficult to have
conversations with like guys I work with
because everybody wants to complain or
something it's and I up to that point I
I I feel like I don't want to contribute
to that anymore and I just Hey listen to
this so one time um it was 20 years ago
it was yeah it was probably right at 20
years ago um he's become a close friend
of mine his name's Eric Peters he's a
musician and a painter here in Nashville
and we were doing some things together
and um I was on stage one night and he
and I was making a joke about my wife
and my wife and I been barely
married and he's a is a small guy and
I'm a big loudmouth idiot and he's a
smaller guy and kind of quiet and very
uh very Arty artistic he's amazing and
he just like casually said hey you know
what there's two kinds of husbands the
husbands
that spend time making fun of their
wives and husbands that will never say a
negative thing and he said don't be the
first kind the world has enough of them
that's for weak men and I remember
thinking dude I'm going to try my best
to not say anything negative about my
wife especially public ever now that's
not mean I don't talk to my closest
friends or a therapist or something but
anyway I applaud you brother for not
contributing to being like yeah dude
then my girl my don't be that guy I'm
proud of you dude that's awesome okay
let's walk through this so the word
empowerment simply means I want to give
her what she needs oh go ahead go ahead
go ahead I got that I I often listen
listen to books that you recommend to
your callers and one of those books was
by Terren real I don't want to talk
about yeah that's where I got this idea
about um empowering my wife because he
said that's one of the things he does
when he recognizes like a depressed
husband he'll he'll immediately like
empower the wife and I was like that
just was like oh my gosh I need to focus
on that was beautiful did you like the
book I did yeah that's awesome man all
right so what like let's just Define it
empowering simply means I'm going to
give her what she needs to be
successful okay I like it so often we
think especially men here's what you
need to be successful a hammer or a
wrench because those are the only two
tools we have in our toolkit all right
so I'm going to give you a couple of
different toolkits Fair yep okay um
toolkit number one gosh dude and by the
way every man listening to this is don't
let your eyes roll through the back of
your head I just want you to ask
yourself is what you're doing working
and most men will go all right right not
really so I'm going to give you a
different set of tools and you're going
to be like oh dude you simp you whatever
whatever I'm telling you one works and
one doesn't okay here we go the first
one is no telling her she needs to fill
in the blank you need to go to
counseling you need do this I'm not
getting your meds until you that's a
failed track okay you will you will join
the ranks of a million people in her
life perceptively her perception that a
million people don't get her don't
understand her or coming after her okay
yeah so your strange challenge is how do
I remain on her team while at the same
time Empower her and not enable her
right oh yeah that's where I'm that's
where I'm I I I'm really good at
enabling her I know exactly what you
mean by that okay so here's what we're
going to
do number one we're going to sit down
and you're going to say I want to be the
best husband I can
be it would really help me if you dot
dot
here's what I want you to give her two
or three very small tasks can you help
sit up to coffee in the morning would
you be willing to do a budget with me on
Sunday nights and talk about our
calendar coming up this week for
me and what you're doing is and this
sounds manipulative it's not it's
empowering her you're giving her a
couple of small tiny tasks so she can
get a couple of small wins relationally
and operationally she can see the coffee
being made she can see you smile after
you all do a quick budget meeting or a
quick calendar meeting on Sunday night
an invitation to get involved in small
things giving her a chance to win and
then letting her see it all over
you like three days into her making the
coffee in the morning you going hey I
just need to
stop I need you to hear me say every
single part of my morning and my day is
better because you
have stepped into this gap for me thank
you and she'll be like oh my gosh it's
like two seconds and you'll be like I
know and it makes such a difference for
me thank you okay that's beautiful right
um and so what we're looking for is a is
a series of little wins okay and you can
pick whatever that looks like I like
that okay number
two ask her hey it's year seven of us
being
married this is when husbands realize
they need to get better at what they do
would you be willing to go to counseling
with me cuz I want to be better at
husbanding and it has nothing to do with
her other than she's going to be able to
contribute to help
you I've tried that but it was it it I
don't think the context was right at the
time but now it might be better to try
if you say hey I don't I don't know how
to be married to you our marriage is
falling apart you're going through this
I we need to go to counseling that's
going to be tough yeah but hey would you
love me enough to come help me
out see how that it's subtle but you end
up in the same place you both end up on
a
couch y okay a third one is
structure can you create a 30 minute
meeting on Sunday evenings just say I'll
make dinner on Sunday nights moving
forward into this new year but would you
just do a quick R so we can talk through
the week
I find myself spinning out and I get
stressy and I don't want to bring
stressy home so if we can just run
through the calendar any dinners we have
this week any workouts we need to go do
whatever um would you do that with
me but what's going to happen after
month one and month two and month three
and month four of course you're going to
miss a couple of times but what you're
going to slowly build over time is this
relational safety through an activity
most people think relational safety
comes from just talking a
lot it truly comes from accomplishing a
thing together something is small as a
calendar uh discussion
okay that's that's great I like I really
like that 30 minute just simple meeting
starting out once a week and build on
that but the and and let it know let her
know this is for you not for
her m
okay okay can you help
me because she loves you and she's
struggling and when we go ahead this is
difficult for me to ask for help I know
i' it is really tough I I I the whole
enabling thing I try to take on so much
and but you see you hear me say this on
my show all the time and uh Terry real
talks about too there's a dance that
happens and the dance becomes somebody
struggling with ADHD and depression and
anxiety this they feel like their body
and their feelings are bigger than their
abilities and then they marry somebody
who hates asking for help and solves all
of their problems all the time yeah and
so the ability to stand up on your own
two feet never happens because I don't
ever have to and the person who is
trying to uh achieve love For Love by
fixing stuff never grasps it it feels
like a ghost every time you take and get
the car oil changed or you do it
yourself or you fix the drywall patch or
whatever that you earn some money you're
expecting this now she'll fill in the
blank and it
doesn't
right right so what we're doing is we're
flipping the whole thing on its
head and by the way I'm telling you this
is all for her this will help you
too yeah okay yeah now there's a couple
of very nerdy things that I want you to
try also that are super kind of woo woo
but I want to give it a shot okay no
wooo is fine yeah let's hear it I want
you to try four times a day right when
you wake up right before you leave right
when you get home from work like walk in
the door or she walks in the door from
work and then right before yall go to
sleep I want you to try SOS skin on skin
contact does not have to be sexual you
don't to take your shirts off or
anything you can but you hold hands
under the covers you can just touch
feet okay you hug and when you hug you
can put your hand on the back of her
neck underneath her hair and she can do
the same thing to
you okay skin on-skin contact four times
a day for about 10 15 30 seconds if you
want to get
weird okay and one of those times
probably right when you get home from
work or right before you go to bed I
want you to say hey I read this
obnoxious thing that supposedly can help
my heart
rate and but I want you to uh make eye
contact with me comfortably and weird
for about 15 seconds would you do
that okay now there is some this is this
is me going out on a limb here okay this
is me taking one set of Science and
another set of Science and cobbling
together and I don't have I haven't read
this study okay so I'm I'm hoping that a
plus b will equal C here it might not
but I think it will okay okay 15 seconds
here's what here's why there's some
significant research that
says um eye contact for somebody who
struggles with social anxiety with
anxiety disorders of some of some sorts
it actually heightens their arousal
makes things worse
okay and makes things worse yes but but
hang on we also know that the research
on anxiety suggests you have to go
through it to give your body
peace and so when you avoid something
your body actually it reinforces the
anxiety
so most of the time you hear the studies
it says x s anxiety disorder plus eye
contact equals a heightening of the
anxiety so it's natural to go well dude
let's just avoid eye contact but
actually what that does is it makes the
anxiety
stronger okay so here's what I want to
do I want her to begin to feel and
experience you as
safe okay okay she probably does that
intellectually she knows you'll fight
for her she know you can fix stuff right
yes I want her to feel that in her
nervous system okay I want her to feel
that too yes okay so let's get
weird okay and anybody listening to this
I think there's a benefit to this but I
want y'all to make eye contact in a
weird way and you'll laugh at first and
she'll want to look away and every time
one of y'all looks away um I want you to
start the 15 seconds over
again but here's what I want her to see
I want your eye crinkles to come out and
I want your eyes to soften when you're
looking in her eyes that's it and when
it's over be like that's it 15 seconds
we're done high five yeah you high five
whatever I want this to become a
practice on a daily basis and say Hey I
want to do a 30-day challenge that I
heard about on some internet
show okay okay after about a week of her
helping you with coffee um filling your
gas up filling your carp with gas
whatever little small tasks you ask hey
can you support me here
I want you to write her a letter and put
on her
pillow and let her know that this week's
been one of the greatest weeks of your
life she can dismiss things that you say
people with depression and especially uh
ADHD can dismiss it anxiety can dismiss
the words or they can hear them
differently than you speak them but when
you write things down they go back and
they go back and they go back and they
go
back okay or if maybe if you want to get
super gangster if she D actually do this
she might not if yall have a journal
that you put on each other's pillow at
night I'll write in it tonight I'll put
on her journal she can read it and
respond to it and then I'll go back to
mine okay
okay I've been meaning to write a letter
I've been do a meeting to do that that's
awesome and maybe you take it out and if
for for the start of the new
year
um you read it to her and then you give
it to
her
okay I like that now I want everyone
listening and you two to hear none of
this was about talking to her about her
depression anxiety or
ADHD it's not okay it's about giving her
body a
space and a person to
go and in a weird way you are going to
begin to grow too cuz you already do the
stuff right you exercise you're you can
yeah snap into slim JY you do all that
stuff all that good stuff Y what I want
to do is connect with
her exactly yes and from that connection
only then can there be a conversation
about
um I'm gonna go pick up your
meds um or when she's decides I'll go
talk to a counselor for you so you can
become a better husband fine I love you
that
much yeah that maybe she extracts some
benefit from
it
very nice he's giving me quite a few
things here to really think about and
contemplate and put into action cool and
by the way it sounds weird to talk to to
for you to picture your wife and to ask
to think how am I gonna help her by
asking her to help me with a
thing yeah it's it is it's it's it's
it's it's sensitive and it's there's
some fear in me I'm not going to lie I
have to admit it's scary to have
difficult conversations like that better
and uh I know I'm not the best at it yet
I don't I'm work I I'm reading a lot and
sometimes reading a lot of books I like
I've read all of your books I read about
five years in the
work making myself better included and
then it can get overwhelming sometimes
all the information you get right and
and I'm gonna tell you quit reading
you've already read my two books
right uh yeah okay quit reading I just
want to make sure you bought my books
before I that I'm just playing but
listen U let's stop reading for a while
let's start doing let's start
doing yeah that's that's the part it
sometimes that's where it gets
overwhelming you're like okay now I need
to start practicing these a lot of these
things I'm learning about and it's like
okay well I don't really know how where
do you start and it makes me you're
overwhelmed and you don't even know
where to begin and so dude you just said
it
perfect if I could get every husband in
the United States to say what you just
said I think our culture would change
overnight and that is
honey I'm not very good at
this but I'm going to start trying
something
new I'm still going to protect us I'm
still going to provide for us I'm still
going to take care of us I'm still going
to co-parent I'm going to do all those
things and yeah I feel that
okay
and I want I want to practice I want to
learn how to connect with
you and going to go what we do connect
we do oh God this about sex no no no no
no no this is about me learning how to
listen and me learning how to like
practice new things I read all these
great books I want to start practicing
it could you help me with in the
following ways a weekly meeting would
you be willing to do that for
me there's three things in the morning
before I go to work that are just I I
just always find myself struggling with
it it would change my life if you would
help me with
these and by the way if she doesn't
that's fine it may not be time for her
yet she may still be struggling or she
gets three days and the fourth day
there's no coffee in there you can make
it all yeah don't take it personally
yeah but it's a little wins little wins
I like that little wins
cool cool all right hang on the line I'm
G to send you both of the questions for
humans for couples here's what these are
going to give you guys
a just a quiet path in the woods for new
conversations what we're doing here is
we're building intimacy we are healing
nervous
systems and if once a week at your uh
calendar meeting if youall just have a a
quick hey um let's let's do three
questions or let's go for a drive let's
go out for to eat um somewhere cheap and
we're going to do some qu whatever it
looks like now me and my wife started
driving um we've gotten several
questions since now we when we drive we
just do it I just like it I learn new
things about my wife the person I've
been with for a quarter Century all the
time and and vice versa and um dude I'm
so proud of you it's an honor to get to
get to talk to you and get to know you
if um you'll try some of these things
I'd love to hear how it goes okay I'd
love to hear how it goes and please make
sure your wife continues with her
medical care and continues to work with
a medical provider who's encouraging her
to go to counseling the evidence is
abundantly clear that medication plus
therapy is the gold standard so we got
to get her in there some point but we're
going to do it a different way not by
pointing fingers but by opening our
chests up a little bit opening up our
souls and saying um I don't know how to
do this but uh let's try connecting I'm
proud of you brother I'm glad to know
you're in the community with
me